When you've used Ping,
it's given your numbers for
the round trip time between you and
the machine you're pinging.
But what exactly is a round trip time?
It's pretty much what it sounds like.
Your machine can't tell
how long it takes for
a packet to get from
it to the other end.
But it can tell how much time
has elapsed between when it sent
that packet and
when it received a response.
That's the round trip involved.
So there's this famous book about
a ping traveling out from its
host to a destination and going through
all these hops in the middle and
eventually coming back to where it
started taking a long round trip.
Okay actually this book is about a duck
but Pings are kind of like ducks.
They usually move in groups all in a row
just like those pings that we saw in
the terminal were just like
these famous ducks in Boston.
Round trip time is an important
measurement of closeness on the network.
But Ping time, as it's often called,
isn't the only measurement of
performance across a network.
We'll see some other ones
later in this lesson.